[Musique]
l'Espace Rambouillet c'est un parc
forestier animalier qui est dédié à à
tout ce qui est présenter l'écosystème
forestier ses animaux pour sensibiliser
le plus grand nombre à la biodiversité
et sa
préservation depuis qu'on a ouvert au
mois d'avril on a un petit train
électrique qui permet en fait fait aux
jeunes enfants et aux personnes qui ont
des difficultés pour se déplacer de
découvrir la forêt sauvage on a
euh la partie la forêt des mil écureuil
où là on va avoir la présentation sur
des trampolines géants qui sont
installés entre les
arbres on met en place un événement avec
des spectacles et des animations donc du
spectacle vivant avec de la pyrotechnie
on est vraiment sur une thématique qui
allie la magie le côté onyrique et
féérique on va avoir un dieu cel qui
arbore des bois de serr qui va
rencontrer une Driade donc une une une
nymphe des des bois de la forêt on va
avoir des cavaliers de
[Musique]
lumière